[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to vm's end
to end where we are talking about you
know how to use virtual machines compute
engine with other services on google
cloud and outside um
for the next few episodes it's going to
be just myself and a guest
and our guest today we're bringing back
katie mclaughlin welcome katie hello
again brian
ready and super excited because we're
going to talk about
cloud run today
so
i always like to start off with kind of
an overview of things you know so you
know what is cloud run well brian have
you ever wanted to run cobol in the
cloud
or lisp
i'm not sure if i have a fortran
anything that you can put into a
container you can run it on cloud run
as long as when cloud run gets it it can
say are you listening on a port yes you
are okay i will serve you now
doesn't matter what's inside the
container
okay that's really cool so that um
like one of the big challenges with um
there's a lot of different ways to run
containers these days
um so that that kind of helps like get
to part of you know what what is special
and unique about cloud run so it's it's
anything you can put in a container
that's listening on a port um can you
tell me a little more that's basically
the gist of the cloud run runtime
container contract if you give it a
container and it can listen on a port
then it will run it for you
and that's all you have to provide there
are many other services where you have
to
create your own cluster specify um how
many instances how many nodes all that
stuff if you need that level of
complexity you go for it you do you but
if you don't
then cloud run might be the compute
platform for you because you just give a
container it's like here here's my
container i would like you to run it
please and thank you and that's all you
need to do awesome so we're going to get
load balancing and
you know scaling and that kind of stuff
just for free that's part of the deal
yeah
cool
so
then i guess the the question is from
your perspective like how does this fit
in
with systems that have vms or you know
actually just you know google cloud as a
whole
ah well now that you mention it i did
see a couple of weeks ago a really cool
demo by richard serrota where he took a
go service and deployed it onto google
cloud function second generation
which uses containers so he provided the
go
file and the dependencies that he needed
cloud cloud functions
packaged that all up created a container
told it how to run the service because
it's go
you compile go and then you just run the
executable and then he took the
container that was created by cloud
functions
and deployed it to cloud run
and deployed it to gke
and deployed it to compute engine
because brian i'm sure you're aware you
can run containers on compute engine
absolutely it's one of the the lesser
known features you can you know just
start it right from the console
um
so
i mean i love this like this because i i
think of our different compute bits as
kind of an abstraction stack you know
and you've got the higher abstraction
things like functions the very top and
then compute engine at the you know the
base of the stack of things um
could could you talk a little more about
like
where did that container come from and
like how did how does that
because each of these systems can run
containers but where did that come from
like and how does it get out i'm i'm
curious about that part
do you remember zip files
how you could
zip something up you can compress it you
can just here is a thing you can send it
to uh your person on a mac or person on
windows and you can expand it all out
and there's all your stuff in this
common file format
containers are just layers of tar files
with a little bit of json metadata
around it but it is a now standardized
packaging format and that's basically
what it is now and there are many
different things not just docker that
can create containers uh
google cloud functions second generation
uses a system called build packs
which detects the language that you're
using and does common tasks so for
python it'll install from your
requirements.txt and then it'll ask it
how do you want to run your service
for go it'll compile it then run the
executable and then it'll put it all
together in a nice little container and
send it off
to be run whenever you need it
got it so yeah so then it ends up on
cloud run or on
you could use that same thing on
kubernetes and on vms
nice so that that brings us down the
stack
um the last time we talked you mentioned
this
migrate to containers thing
as well does that that seems like it's
going the other direction am i right
sometimes you can't start with
a
greenfield or brand new system sometimes
you have your special
carefully crafted sculpted cared for
snowflake vm
that you need to do something about
because it's a little bit special and a
little bit fragile so you can run
migrate to containers which can help you
containerize
that vm and then from there you can
extract out the process you want to run
on cloud run and that will help you with
your lift and shift process very aptly
named
where you can take your very bespoke
special compute agent and start the
process to evolving that into a more
robust microservice architecture that
still surprises me that that works but i
love i love that that exists to kind of
pull processes apart and like make
containers for them and so
um so we really
are in the space where the the tooling
is getting good to help us out with this
moving up and down the layers of
distractions you know if you get into
containers somehow either kind of from
the bottom up or the top down then you
have this flexibility for
for moving around how how would if we
have this flexibility you know how would
you recommend you know people
think about deciding you know where
something lives and in particular what
is a really good fit for cloud run it
depends what you want to have to worry
about
in compute engine you have complete
control over everything from your os to
the architecture to gpus
right at the top of the abstraction
there's a choice of a number of
languages and it will run a function
that one is called cloud functions it is
aptly named a function or a method if
your programming language defines a
chunk of code as a method not a function
that's what it'll do and cloud run is in
the middle where in functions you run
one function in compute engine you can
run multiple processes cloud run will do
a process with many functions
so you can see how you can get the
complexity
variation there depending on what you
actually want to run
and off to the sides you have kubernetes
engine gke if you want to have to do all
the
kubernetes stuff with multiple
processors all interacting and if you
have a web service you can go over into
app engine with its specialized toolset
it's like a little diamond of
possibilities a diamond a diamond of
possibilities i like that a lot
um
what kinds of uh patterns are you seeing
so i
i'm interested in like vms all the time
right especially in this series so i'm
curious you know what kind of patterns
you're seeing people using cloud run
with with vms of course i mean you don't
just have to stick with one compute type
you can change it all up because
brian your special snowflake
vm that you spent all this time crafting
you wouldn't want to install something
on that that might cause issues or
might
make your life a bit harder to maintain
right
it's true yeah so as an isolation and
abstraction mechanism
that image processing service to turn
any image into a thumbnail maybe you
want to deploy that to
cloud functions where you can use
a
java
isolated environment
and have
whatever package you want on there
to do the image manipulation for you and
then you don't have to install java on
your
vm you can just have this function that
does it for you this allows you in your
compute engine instance to basically
call it like an api that you control
it's just the
https url you send it the data maybe a
query string for the height and width
and
a posted payload of the image
and maybe that function will return back
the image to you or
it creates a cloud storage object
and then
there's maybe a pub sub message that you
can listen to to oh my image is ready
now
you can start adding different
mechanisms like this different uh
messaging systems you could
make this a
cloud task that is invoked where you say
ah i have a new thumbnail for you to
process put it in a cloud task queue
which then calls the http endpoint which
will then do the stuff
and let you know when it's done so you
can start building these asynchronous
computational models that uses a variety
of different
compute options from google cloud
including some of our orchestration and
workflow stuff including cloud workflows
which means you can have all these
things chained together and you can
start creating some really interesting
architectures
where you can have your special
snowflake and this service somebody else
wrote in java that they can control
because you are not a java expert let's
say i'm sure you are brian but you can
start having these complex heterogeneous
architectures that can just do anything
you need without having to work out
how do i install and keep java up to
date on my special snowflake machine for
example
that makes a lot of sense so you know
you've got you described like a security
boundary different like language runtime
environments asynchronous like there's a
whole bunch of different kind of
architectural things that that's serving
that's that's nice so this um when
people say lift and shift or move and
improve
i i think this is one of the patterns
you know where like you you've got your
thing and then you can kind of add
additional stuff on to the sides and go
um
so
if somebody is inspired by this
conversation and wants to give that a
try
or you know wants to play with kind of
moving things up and down these
abstractions we talked about um how
would you recommend they learn more or
get started you want to be scrolling
down this video a bit and have a look at
the description where i'll have a
plethora of different links i'll have a
link to richard siroda's demo i'll have
a link to getting started with cloudrun
with cloud functions um some of the
sample micro services that we have you
can see
a python micro service a go micro
service a java micro service you can
deploy these things
under the free tier of cloud run and you
can just start getting your hands on it
try to clip all these different lego
blocks together and see what you can
build
that's how i would suggest getting
started awesome i'm
ready to go poke at some more things so
uh thank you so much for for joining
again
much appreciated anytime brian it's
always delightful to chat to you and
thank you everybody who's watching i
hope uh this was useful uh you get
inspired if you have any questions you
know
comment below or look us up online we
will try to help you out and so thank
you all and see you next time
[Music]
you